vecinos y rescatistas siguen buscando
pero las esperanzas de encontrar
supervivientes disminuyen el malaui
cuatro días después de su paso el ciclón
Freddy ha dejado cientos de Muertos más
de 183 mil desplazados y ha afectado al
menos a 500.000 personas es una de las
peores catástrofes naturales que ha
vivido el país
el número de muertos asciende ahora a
326 Recuerden que la anterior cifra de
Muertos fue de 225 Así que esta es de
100 más con 796 heridos y 200 un
desaparecidos además de la pérdida de
Vidas carreteras y puentes así como
escuelas centros de salud y redes
eléctricas fueron destruidos las
autoridades abrieron más de 300 refugios
de emergencia para acoger a las víctimas
necesitamos comida ropa y sábanas es
difícil sobrevivir sin comida y
necesitamos también encontrar un lugar
donde poder construir Nuevas Casas la
traje ya llega en un momento en que este
país sin salida al mar atraviesa una
profunda crisis la pandemia de Kobe 19
la Guerra de Ucrania han provocado el
colapso de la economía se espera que en
los próximos días se organice un acto de
recaudación de fondos bajo los auspicios
de las Naciones Unidas pero los agentes
humanitarios temen que la atención de
los donantes siga centrada en otras
crisis como la de Ucrania o Turquía
Freddy golpeó dos veces en pocas semanas
la región del sur de África matando a 73
personas en mozambique 17 Madagascar
según la Organización meteorológica
Mundial el ciclón ha empezado a
disiparse pero los expertos han
advertido que el calentamiento de los
océanos está contribuyendo a la
intensificación de estos fenómenos
naturales